face à la flambée des prix de l'énergie
ou encore de l'essence des décisions
étaient attendues ce jeudi soir jean
castex a annoncé le prolongement du gel
des prix du gaz jusqu'à la fin de
l'année prochaine et les experts nous
indiqua qu'à partir d'avril ils
commenceraient leur décrue aujourd'hui
les mêmes experts monsieur boulot que
j'écoute les experts je ne suis pas un
expert des cours mondiaux du gaz nous
disent que vraisemblable en cette décrue
qui interviendra elle sera plus lente
donc nous avons pris nos responsabilités
en maintenant le blocage des prix sur
tout le long de l'année 2022 autre sujet
chaud pour jean castex celui de la
flambée des prix des carburants ces
dernières semaines les français
attendaient un coup de pouce du
gouvernement le premier ministre a
annoncé une aide appelée indemnité
inflation pour soulager la population de
la hausse des prix général nous allons
décider d'une sorte d' indemnité
inflation de 100 euros j'ai parlé de 80
euros tout à l'heure de surcoût de 100
euros qui sera versée
aux français c'est une indemnité classe
moyenne si vous voulez en quelque sorte
aux français qui gagnent moins de 2000
euros nets par mois pour prendre sa
décision le gouvernement s'est fixé sur
le salaire médian en france ce chèque de
100 euros concernera au total 38
millions de français et sera versée à
partir de la fin décembre 2021 par le
biais de cette indemnité jean castex
affirment vouloir protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des français ces dernières
semaines les prix au litre des
carburants ont atteint des sommets avant
les annonces du gouvernement plusieurs
grandes enseignes avaient pris les
devants et annoncé vendre l'essence à
prix coûtant un moment de répit pour les
automobilistes ah ben je viens souvent
ici du coup du jeudi 11 au dimanche
presque pas voilà sinon après sur
l'autoroute c'est en 81 85 même pas la
peine d'y penser parce que là on fait 20
euros voire 30 de plus pour un plan et
ouais c'est compliqué après ça devient
très compliqué ces normes déjà en temps
normal j'ai un gros budget essence en ce
moment c'est à je peux même pu faire le
plein de mon camion puisque les cartes
bleues sont bloqués à 120 euros et je
peux même plus faire le plein
c'est un gros gros budget les annonces
de jean castex interviennent alors que
le spectre de la crise des gilets jaunes
plane sur le gouvernement pour rappel en
novembre 2018 le mouvement des gilet
jaune avait émergé à la suite de
l'augmentation du prix des carburants
près de trois ans plus tard s'il ne
reste que très peu de manifestants sur
les ronds-points de france cette
nouvelle flambée des prix de l'essence
pourrait redonner un coup de fouet à la
conteste